yeah one time in japan i spilled my
popcorn over the floor
and i think that ruined the whole movie
for me
i think that legitimately made the movie
or
what was the movie or it started i don't
even know i don't remember i was just so
i was literally distraught
for the first 40 minutes of the film i
was actually just so sorry i don't buy
popcorn i was
genuinely when i when it fell over you
know when you're so sad about something
bad happening yeah that you just sit
there
for like 10 seconds and just let it soak
about how sad you are
you're like all around
like you know you break like you drop
your phone and it smashes you don't go
like oh my god you're like
yeah you're going to stare at her i
don't even go to pick it up immediately
so overwhelmed with emotions and sadness
that you just stand there yeah now you
get that
and like that i get that feeling but not
when i drop popcorn
no i i mean i i get it it's it's it's
whenever i drop any
kind of food item or drink item i've
just i've broken my phone before i've
broken
expensive items and there is something
that just hurts so much about dropping
food or drink on the floor yeah no
they're just there's nothing can't be
matched there's nothing that hurts me
more than buying a fresh pint yeah and
then
like just like immediately dropping it
or like a pint just falling off a tray
as you're taking it to the table
i think i'd rather drop my first born
child than my problem
if i'm not completely honest with you
laughing at least you can pick it back
up
you know the baby can take a hit you
know i'm pretty sure i took a many hits
my popcorn doesn't take a hit
i can't eat that [ __ ] right now
especially if you pick that up everyone
will look at you yeah exactly
as much as i would want to pick you know
part of me is like is the top layer of
the popcorn on the floor okay at least
can i at least scoop some of it back in
at least it's not directly touching it
yeah it's like how much of this popcorn
has
fallen out i want to say that i'm
hygienic but if i see
if if shut the [ __ ] up if if like let's
say
a bunch of nachos fell on the floor i
would be tempted to just be like no
not nachos not not just where i draw the
line i would be tempted
to be like i would be tempted to be like
the bottom layer is covering the screen
i will grab the top layer and now i
would eat that no
i would eat that like popcorn it comes
in pieces right because
popcorn you can scrape off the top like
yeah so you can scrape off a layer let's
say you could get the you could get the
bucket that you have with it i would
maybe i would like kind of shuffle some
of the top ones back in if they were
if they were what you floated up
slightly
you know tilt it 40 degree angle and see
what i can like kind of scoot back in
from the top layer right that shows for
me it's a little too wet
is way too wet it's like chilly i feel
chilly
like french fries right let's say that
all the french fries fell on the floor a
part of me would be tempted to be like
you know the top forty percent of these
french fries perfect no no no no no
because i'm gonna start grabbing okay
okay yeah
okay because because one okay so so
there are two that sounds so vile to
something
and i'm the same there are two factors
you need to consider one
what is the ground is it like a clean
cut
no no no because if it's if it's carpet
clean carpet
is the worst carpet's the worst because
you got like all the [ __ ] and like yeah
all the dust and [ __ ] if you drop on the
street floor that's just like
that's game over you you have to say
goodbye
right there wood laminate flooring okay
okay yeah yeah okay maybe maybe
we can salvage most of this yeah
secondly you need to consider what is
the food item that you've just dropped
right is is it liquid you know how how
viscous is
like like popcorn it comes in little
pieces you can just you can just like
scoop off the bottom layer and just
leave that on the floor and just
like it's it's like the safety layer you
have like the bottom layer and then a
safety layer just in case
any of anything on the second layer yeah
yeah yeah yeah what if you drop a
chocolate bar on the floor you just like
pick it up and scrape it off
with a dirt chocolate bar
chocolate bar yeah honestly it depends
like it's a rinse it's a solid piece of
food right so it depends on the floor
that it's touching i treat it like an
indian escargot i just kind of blow up
just blow off the dust it's like yeah
it's good enough
i've got an immune system for one week
later we have the roanoke
i won't do it now but like during high
school like if i you know like dropped a
sandwich for example right like
depending on how it landed like if the
sandwich perfectly lands on the ground
yeah that bottom piece of bread rips
you're tearing that piece off let's face
it yeah i'm taking everything else on
top of it yeah yeah
yeah i'm not wasting food [ __ ] that like
how you like that slowly went from yeah
oh disgusting too wait maybe
maybe there's the situation i don't want
to waste food man
the point is i would rather drop my
child yeah
tldr i'm pretty sure my parents dropped
me
i'm pretty sure i'm i'm fine right
i think the single parenthood didn't
drop their child come on now
this is what this is why i am terrified
of holding a child i don't think i've
actually
i don't think i've in my 30 years of
being alive i don't think i've properly
held a baby in my life
i've seen people in japan where they're
on their bikes they have the kid in the
carriage behind them and they have the
kid in the backpack
yeah yeah yeah i'm like this is just
this is that's hard mode this is an
accident waiting to happen
like if the sketch is [ __ ] whichever
way you fall you are cushioning
oh god just kidding
i don't know that's why that's why i
never understand whenever you know one
of my family members has a baby or
something and then dead ass look me in
the eye and go
do you want to hold this baby and i'm
just like why would you trust
so why would you trust a literal life in
my hands
like i don't trust myself to hold that
does this thing come with a [ __ ]
instruction manual
like how do i operate this thing yeah i
always wonder like
like i'm like how do you do you like
pick up it like do you kind of like take
it for somebody who has many pictures of
me hold your babies i can tell you
if you take it from the bottom or like
under the ah yeah you do like this you
like kind of like rest them like this
now but like when i was like 14.
who told you how to do it no one's ever
told me how to properly hold
instinct trial
[Music]
i think because like i i i'm terrified
of it because
every single time bar none that i've
tried to hold a pet
it's trying to wriggle out and
and i'm just thinking [ __ ] if this
[ __ ] animal is trying to wriggle out
my grasp i do not
want to hold a human life in my hands
and risk dropping a human life
they just complain yeah they're like
british people i don't think i've ever i
don't think i've ever seen a baby like
get held by someone and be like [ __ ] off
me
what are you doing like no